okay so um next we'll have mary ruders
who's an assistant professor of
computer science and also of electrical
engineering at stanford university
um she's interested in theoretical
computer science and the theoretical
aspects of engineering
especially concerning communication
storage and data processing some topics
include air correcting codes randomized
algorithms dimensionality reduction and
more
her phd thesis won
the eatcs distinguished dissertation
award as well as
the myers memorial prize from the umich
math department and she's won several
other awards as well including
an ieee information theory society james
l massey award this year
and also she's a fantastic teacher
winning
a teaching award at stanford i guess
three years in a row it sounds like um
so i guess that means it's gonna be a
really good presentation
no pressure all right okay so um thanks
so much all right thanks very much uh
jelani for the generous introduction um
yeah thanks everyone for coming thanks
for the invitation um it's such an honor
to get to be here today and i'm really
excited to talk to you about uh coding
for uh storage and computation um but
first uh i would like to wish a very
heartfelt happy birthday to the simons
institute
um
i just cannot emphasize enough uh how
important the simons institute has been
for my own intellectual life and and
growth over these past 10 years
i was fortunate enough to be in the very
first class of simon's institute fellows
back in 2013
um so when i was still a graduate
student uh and since then i've had the
opportunity to come back many times um
and yeah every time i come i uh you know
i encounter new ideas i form new
collaborations um i get whole new
research agendas uh i think i'd be in a
very different place right now uh
certainly intellectually and then
probably also personally if not for the
simon's institute so um thank you very
much to the simon's institute thank you
to those who've made it possible for
these past 10 years um yeah and here
here's to another another 10 years
yeah the time it took me to do that uh
powerpoint animation is a testament to
my devotion to the sciences
okay um so what am i actually going to
talk about today
so this is actually a pretty difficult
talk to write so i was asked to speak
about coding theory generally and i
figured that such a talk in this venue
should probably check at least three
boxes uh so first um you know i i should
probably touch on and celebrate a decade
of coding theory at the simons institute
um second i guess i should talk about
some of my own work because i'm giving
the talk uh and and third i wanted to
give a sense of you know what's exciting
in coding theory right now and sort of
what what are some interesting future
directions
um
and so uh
this is challenging because there's a
lot of things here um right so just in
this in this first box uh you know a
decade of coding theory at the simons
institute it's been a very exciting
decade in coding theory
um these are just a few things that i
could come up with until i ran out of
room on the slide and a lot of these
have happened at the coding at the
simons institute or have been built on
things that happened at the simons
institute
of course i had nothing to do with most
of these so let's just pass on the
second box there but in the third box i
do have plenty of visions for the future
both inspired by some of these exciting
uh advances up top and also by emerging
technologies
uh so
yeah i think in a half hour talk there's
just no way i can do justice to all of
this um so in instead i'm going to not
uh so i'm just going to acknowledge that
there's been a you know very exciting
decade of coding theory in the simons
institute has played an integral role
but what i'm going to do today is tell a
much more narrow story i think um
that that i do think checks all three
boxes but maybe doesn't quite do justice
to all of them certainly not to the
first one okay so the more narrow story
that i'm going to tell you about um has
to do as you can tell from the title of
the talk with coding for storage and
computation
um so this story starts okay not quite a
decade ago at the simons institute but
rounding up close enough so back back in
in 2015
um with a question about coding for
distributed storage
um and also with an answer to that
question uh that i worked on with venkat
garaswami back in 2015 um at the simons
institute so the first part of the talk
i'm gonna sort of tell you what that
question is and what our answer was
um it's going to sort of segue into the
second part of the talk which is some
some more recent work so i want to tell
you about a piece of work that i did
recently with noah shetty who's here
about coding for computation
and as you'll see when i get there uh
this uh work sort of
uh sort of directly arises from the work
uh that we did at the simons institute
back in 2015. um so that'll be the
second part of the talk and then that
will sort of segue into the third part
of the talk visions for the future and i
want to talk a little bit about this
notion of coding for computation in
particular computing on top of error
correcting codes um so this is something
that i think has been showing up a lot
recently or i think it's been showing up
for a while but maybe i've been noticing
it more recently that i think is a
really interesting future direction and
maybe deserves more study okay so this
is the outline of the talk so let's get
started um with the the sort of the
first bullet point so distributed
storage and a walk down memory lane okay
so let's um travel back in time to 2015
at the simons institute so it's the boot
camp for the information theory semester
um and uh alex demarcus is giving one of
the boot camp talks um
about coding for modern distributed
storage systems for um so he's at the
end of the talk the open problem slide
and uh so i was in the audience and
there's an open problem here that really
caught my eye um it's that one uh but
let me write that in a larger font um so
what what alex asked was can one get
better repair bandwidth for read solomon
codes
okay so that's some coding theory jargon
but without the coding theory jargon
essentially what that's asking is can
you do communication efficient
polynomial interpolation
um so actually just as an aside this is
a talk about coding theory but almost
all the technical stuff i'm going to
talk about is is really just stuff about
polynomial interpolation and so even if
you're not into coding theory um
everyone's into polynomial interpolation
right so there's got to be got to be
something for everybody here
okay um yeah so what is this question i
need to define this a little bit more um
so here's here's the setup um so this
will be the setup for the entire talk so
um
pay attention um
yeah so uh the idea is we want to store
some data uh in a distributed fashion on
n nodes so we have some data f it's
going to be a vector of length k over
some finite field capital f and think of
capital f as being kind of large we want
to store this data on n different
storage nodes
and the catch is that some of the nodes
might fail like that
right and uh
our our goal is to store this data so
that it's
so that we don't lose any data if
if a node fails so we want to basically
add some redundancy
fortunately this is exactly what error
correcting codes are for there's a
beautiful classical solution to this
problem
known as read solomon codes so this has
been around since the 60s
it's ubiquitous both in theory and in
practice and and here's how it works
um so we're gonna first pick n
evaluation points alpha one up through
alpha n in our field f
and then we're going to treat our data
as a polynomial so we'll define a
polynomial f of x whose coefficients are
sort of these data elements so it's a
polynomial of degree k minus 1 and then
we're just going to evaluate this
polynomial on all of those points and
send
all those evaluations off to the
different nodes
right so far so good um so that's it
that's the scheme
and it turns out that this is a great
idea for
tolerating failures this can tolerate
the optimal number of failures so to see
why imagine that say n minus k nodes
fail
um and i claim we haven't lost any data
because we still have k nodes remaining
right and
we have this degree k minus one
polynomial
and we can do polynomial interpolation
right two points determine a line three
points determine a quadratic k points
determine a degree k minus one
polynomial so here we have k evaluation
points we can do polynomial
interpolation we'll cover all of our
data life is good
um yeah so for this reason read solomon
codes are very popular choice i'm
actually in practice for distributed
storage systems
uh okay great um
so we can handle this sort of worst-case
setting but this really is kind of a
worst case setting so what happens uh
most of the time in data centers is not
that like you know everything goes down
at once but rather just like one node
goes down at a time so what happens if
just one node fails so let's say that
one over there
so now we would like to set up a
replacement node there it is and this
replacement node should have exactly the
same information that was on the failed
mode so in this case it wants f of alpha
i so our polynomial evaluated at at this
evaluation point and it needs to figure
out what that data is by contacting all
of the other nodes
so
uh
how can we do this well we just saw one
way to do it uh it can just contact k of
the surviving nodes any k it likes
download uh the contents of each of them
so that's all of these evaluation points
do the polynomial interpolation
and compute f of alpha i that's so
that's what it wants to do
and that works great
uh but this seems like it might be a
little bit wasteful right essentially
what we're doing here is we're
downloading enough information to
recover all of the data
we're computing just this little bit
that we want to keep and throwing away
the rest
so it's very natural to ask can we do
better
so the first thing we might try is
okay maybe we can contact fewer nodes
right instead of contacting k nodes i'm
going to contact like k minus 1.
can we do this
i'm seeing a chorus of head shakes very
good yeah we cannot do this um
basically this is like saying i'm going
to give you two points on a parabola
tell me what the third one is right that
third point could be anything and
there's always some parabola that goes
through those three points so actually
we learn absolutely nothing about that
last evaluation if we only contact k
minus one nodes
okay so we can't do better in this way
and actually before i saw alex's talk
way back in 2015 uh i i think this is
where i thought the story ended
we can't do any better um too bad that's
the price we pay for the wonders of read
settlement codes
um but it turns out what alex's talk
talk taught me back then is actually we
there is some way that we might hope to
do better and that is by contacting more
nodes but downloading less information
from each
so for example uh could look something
like this so the model here is that each
node gets to do some local computation
based on what it's storing and also on
the identity of the failed node and then
some send some message whatever it wants
uh down to the replacement node here so
it could be just like a single bit could
be five bits whatever
and from the information that this node
receives it's supposed to be able to
recover the missing evaluation point
so codes that work in this model are
called regenerating codes so these have
been around since about 2010 they're
introduced by democracy at all and
regenerating codes are basically just
codes that allow you to do this so they
allow for low bandwidth reconstruction
of one or maybe just a few failed
symbols
um
okay so what do we know about
regenerating codes so remember we're
time traveling now so it's 2015. so what
do we know in 2015 um
so we know of optimal constructions of
regenerating codes
uh but none of these are reid's element
codes right so that is to say we know of
different ways of getting the data you
know adding redundancy and putting it on
those storage nodes that has all of
these desirable properties um but
they're not gotten sort of by following
this recipe of treating your data as a
low degree polynomial and evaluating it
at a bunch of points
um so that's great but uh you know
reselling codes are sort of actually
what are used in practice um for
distributed storage they have a number
of uh other sort of desirable properties
um and also we just love polynomial
interpolation uh so it'd be really cool
to to be able to to figure out how to do
this for resolving codes
um and
uh so just a year ago um in 2015 so in
2014 there was this really cool result
by shang mugam at all uh who sort of
gave a proof of concept to show that
actually you could do this so i found
this quite surprising
um so they showed that for specific read
solomon codes so like when n equals five
or n equals six
uh they showed that you you can actually
do this non-trivially so they figured
out like what are the messages that
these nodes have to send you know for
this n equals five code uh
in order to you know get some progress
here um i thought this was was really
surprising and exciting and alex's
question so now getting back to this
talk uh hopefully now we have sort of
the context to understand what this
means um he was asking basically can we
do this more generally like can you do
it for any n could you even hope to do
it optimally like that would be cool
um and
once again this sort of polynomial
interpolation version is can we do sort
of low communication one point
polynomial interpolation
all right
okay so that's the question um really
caught my eye and so i started working
on it at the simons institute with
venkat guraswamy and um okay spoiler
alert the answer is yes we we can do
better
um
uh so again this is joint work with it's
done guru swami and one
uh
sort of
prototypical parameter regime that our
work says you can do better in is the
following so i'm just going to sort of
show you a cartoon to give you a flavor
of the type of result we can get
um
uh so in this cartoon uh n
does pointer work see that all right
there we go n is equal to 2 times k
so we sort of have 2x overhead here and
we're going to be working uh over a
field f of size 2 to the t which is also
equal to n so that means that these
evaluation points alpha 1 up through
alpha n are just all of the points in
the field and the field has size 2 to
the t
nothing about that is particularly
important for the setting except the
fact that it's an extension field so it
needs to be an extension field but
beyond that this can all sort of
generalize
okay but in that setting the picture
gets particularly nice and it looks like
this uh
when we're storing our data as a read
solomon code and one node disappears we
can reconstruct it by downloading just
one bit from all of the surviving nodes
all right so quantitatively what does
that mean
uh okay so the number of bits that we're
downloading total right this is sort of
the the parameter of interest is n minus
one which in this case is roughly 2k
um so let's compare that to the naive
scheme so in the naive scheme we'd
contact k nodes and download
all the information from each of them
all the information is one whole field
symbol that's log of n bits so that's k
log n bits total so we're basically
saving a log factor and moreover you can
show that uh 2k bits is optimal even
even at leading constant two
um at least within certain um classes of
codes
uh
so yeah so that was
pretty nice i found this to be quite
surprising um
okay so how does this work uh so due to
time considerations
i'm not going to actually tell you the
scheme but i am going to tell you sort
of the high level framework for it
because it's going to show up again
um so
here's the the basic idea
for for how this works
so we have our field f and remember that
basically the only important thing about
f is that it's an extension field which
means that it's a field of um order you
know q to the t for some cube so here
we're taking it to be order two to the t
um and f two to the t is a vector space
over f2 which means that if it's been a
while since algebra you can just think
about it as
a bunch of binary vectors of length t
right so we have a bunch of binary
vectors of length t and that's sort of
our our alphabet that we're working with
um
and we're going to use this linear
structure
um so
the way we make our scheme is the
following so for all i we're going to
define some special subspaces w1 w2 up
to wn that have the following properties
so first um the dimension of each wj is
t minus one so it has co-dimension one
um in this two-dimensional space so it's
like a you know hyperplane or it's like
half of the half of a hypercube right
um
and uh then there'll be another property
um which i will read in a moment with
the aid of a picture so here's my
picture um so on the x-axis here i have
the evaluation points on the y-axis i
have the field f
um
and then here i have these subspaces
that we're going to define so each one
of these subspaces is like half of the
field so i've tried to draw this to be
like roughly half of the length of the
y-axis
all right
um okay and then this other property
that we want from these subspaces is the
following
for any polynomial of degree less than k
if alpha alpha j is in wj for all j not
equal to i that is if you have some low
degree polynomial that passes through
all of these blue bars
then it must be the case that at alpha i
that polynomial should be equal to zero
so that's the
that's the requirement
so it might be many polynomials that go
through these um blue blocks here but
all of them need to need to vanish it
alpha
and i claim that if we can come up with
a bunch of such subspaces then we're
done
okay
so why is that the case
well the scheme we're going to use is
the following so each node remember each
node is just allowed to say one bit and
the one bit that that node is going to
send is
are
is it the case that what i'm holding is
that in wj or not so they'll either send
yes or no f of alpha j is in wj or no
it's not
um and i claim that this will be enough
to
distinguish f of alpha i so why is that
the case it's basically just
linearity
so suppose that f is the right answer so
we're after f alpha f of alpha i and and
g is the wrong answer so g of alpha i is
different i want to show you that we're
never going to confuse the two
um so let's consider the polynomial f
minus g
so since f of alpha i is not equal to g
of alpha i then this difference is not
going to vanish on alpha i so it doesn't
go through this point
um so therefore by our property there
must be some alpha j so that it doesn't
go through the corresponding rectangle
so f minus g alpha j is not in wj for
some j
but then that means that f of alpha j
and g of alpha j have sort of different
statuses with respect to w j
right either one of them is in and the
other one is out or the other one is out
and the one of them is in if they were
both in or both out then their
difference would be in
so they sort of have different statuses
but that's exactly what we wanted that
means that node j would return one
answer for f and a different answer for
g and we can distinguish them
so therefore we won't confuse f of alpha
i
with any imposter g of alpha i right so
then we'll get the right answer
um so i've sort of described this in a
non-algorithmic way but you can make
this algorithmic just just by doing some
linear algebra
okay so that's sort of the the framework
um how do we get these subspaces
it's actually it's not so hard um it's a
very explicit easy way to describe them
it fits on one hidden slide uh but for
time i'm going to skip it but ask me
after in a bunch of like five minutes or
something it's not so bad
okay but so that was uh our walk down
memory lane that was back in 2015. uh
what's happened since then
all right so um since then there's
there's actually been quite a lot of
work in this area um so here's uh a
bunch of improvements and extensions um
to our original work um this is sort of
very exciting stuff leading sort of all
the way up into this year and the the
basic punch line of this line of work is
that resolument codes are optimal
regenerating codes not just in that
parameter regime that i showed you on
the earlier slide but actually in a
whole bunch of parameter regimes and
also a whole bunch of extensions of the
model and um yeah and in lots of
different ways so this is a very
exciting
line of work um additionally uh right
this is also a statement about
polynomial interpolation which is just
sort of a generally useful thing shows
up all over the place um and these ideas
have found applications in other areas
as well for example in secret sharing
and in um mpc and secure computation
um
and yeah so like i said this pretty much
takes us up to the present there's a
couple of 22s on this slide and that
sort of segues nicely into the second
part of the talk what i want to talk
about which is some more recent stuff
and this is joint work with noah shutty
um and we're going to talk i'm going to
talk about low bandwidth computation on
read solomon encoded data
okay so
the starting point is the same we have
the same picture we have our data it's
encoded
on these end storage nodes using read
solomon code
but now i'm going to switch up the goal
a little bit so our new goal is the
following
suppose we have a class curly f of
functions
that maps vectors to scalars so it maps
data vectors like this down to elements
of f
and uh
what we'd like to do is compute you know
some function of this
some function in this class on our data
so the model is going to be we have our
stored data possibly some nodes fail and
then some queries shows up who wants to
know what is fee of f
right
and so the querier is going to broadcast
fee and possibly i the identity of the
failed nodes uh to the surviving nodes
they're each going to get to send her a
bit or you know a couple of bits however
much they want um again based on their
own uh
data that they're storing and what they
hear from the queries
and from this the query are supposed to
be able to figure out what is that
function
and the goal is that we want to sort of
minimize the number of bits that go here
so this is a strict generalization of
the problem that we were looking at
before so before this class of functions
was just the class of functions fee sub
i which takes your data and asks what is
the ith evaluation point right
um but you can ask this question more
generally
um and you know i'll maybe i'll give
this a definition let's call it low
bandwidth function evaluation
so the the main result in our work uh is
a low bandwidth function evaluation
scheme
for uh
read solomon codes for linear functions
so that is functions that map our data
vector f to an inner product of v times
f
um again for some finite field
uh so here's sort of
what our result looks like this is a
simplified version with no failures
because this question is actually even
interesting even if there are no
failures which wasn't the case for the
original
problem
so suppose we have our data it's stored
on these nodes
our querier comes up and she wants to
know what is the dot product of
f our data with some query vector v
she's going to broadcast v uh to the
nodes
and each of them are going to recover
just or send her again just one bit so
here sorry i forgot to say the
assumptions for this little toy picture
here are that um once again f is a field
of size two to the t and n is equal to
two to the t uh now n is equal to four k
instead of two k not but
basically the same setup
each of these nodes can send just a
single bit
and this will allow the querier to
recover
this linear function that she's after
right so that's uh one type of result
let me just make a few comments about
this
um so just quantitatively how much are
we downloading
for 4k bits
because there are 4k nodes in one bit
from each
let's compare this to the naive schemes
the naive scheme would be the same as
before we're going to contact k nodes
download all the information
reconstruct all of the data compute the
linear function and then throw the rest
away
that takes omega of k log n bits
and the thing i find really interesting
about this result is that
we need omega of k log n bits to do this
even though there are no failures even
with no coding we would need k log n
bits to do this
so somehow
encoding with an error correcting code
here a reid solomon code
like normally we do this because it
helps
protect us from errors or protect us
from erasures
but here it's actually helping us do
computation somehow the computation that
we've done in doing the encoding is then
useful later we can sort of harness that
later to do
uh
more efficient computation of these
linear functions um i find i find that
to be kind of an interesting phenomenon
um
and uh just note so as before at least
two k bits are are necessary um so we
don't quite have the leading constant
anymore i'm not sure what what the right
constant is it's a good question
um
okay so that's uh sort of the simple
result with no failures we can also
prove a more complicated result that
does have failures so this is the
cartoon for that you can allow any set
of failed nodes uh up to just a smidge
shy of n minus k so n minus k would be
the maximum number that you could
possibly hope
uh to to do and get a similar result
where this one turns into an o of one
and the constant hiding in the big o
depends on how close you are to that n
minus k limit
um
okay
how am i doing on time when do i have to
stop
i meant so okay cool all right yeah so
uh what's the what's the basic idea for
this um well fortunately we've already
seen it um so uh this is exactly the
same slide that we had before i've
modified the picture very slightly and
changed all of the f of alpha i's to
dot product of v and
basically all we were losing before all
we were using before in this framework
was the linearity uh
uh on the coefficients of f like f of
alpha is a linear function of the
coefficients of f and so is this so same
thing holds
so all we need to do is find the
subspaces how do we find them okay it's
a little bit harder now um
actually it's quite a bit harder if you
want to do the failures but for the not
the for the result without failures it's
actually not so bad um you ask me after
the budget maybe like 20 minutes or
something
cool okay so in the remaining i guess
four minutes that i have left i want to
uh talk a little bit about you know
visions for the future
um
uh in particular i want to talk about
this sort of paradigm of computing on
top of error correction which we were
sort of exploring in this work
so i think it's a really natural
question how can we efficiently compute
on top of error correction
actually this is many natural questions
depending on how we define these various
terms
so uh
i showed you some particular ways to
define it in this talk but there are
plenty of other ways that you could
define these things
and these questions you know for these
various permutations show up in many
different domains
um
so i want to just bring a particular
attention to a couple of cases where
they show up where the definition of
efficient is low bandwidth because i've
been seeing this a bunch recently and
this is also part of the motivation um
for the work i just described to you
so when efficient means low bandwidth
meaning that we're going to measure the
total number of bits that are downloaded
here
then yeah this is shown up in a couple
of places so i already told you about
regenerating codes
but another place where this has come up
sort of thinking about more general uh
functional computation is um in
homomorphic secret sharing um so there
are people in this room who know more
about this than i do uh but the the
basic idea here is you want to um you
know share a secret and i'm going to
thinking here about information theory
inflation theoretic
secret sharing so let's say we're doing
shamir scheme or something like that
that's
basically
just doing exactly the same thing of
encoding some data with the reid solomon
code and sending each party a polynomial
evaluation and then the homomorphic part
of homomorphic secret sharing says you
want to compute some function
of the secret
by
uh using a short message from each one
of the parties so this is a very similar
notion to what we just talked about and
in fact our approach does give some kind
of homomorphic secret sharing scheme for
shamir's scheme for linear functions um
but this is a much broader field there's
a whole lot of really exciting stuff
going on and lots of different questions
you can ask um and yeah it's a young
field as you can see
this notion was introduced in in 2016 um
and uh yeah a lot of the questions going
on here kind of have this flavor of low
bandwidth computation on top of the air
correction
especially with smear scheme
another area i want to mention is that
of coded computation
so in coded computation
the basic idea is you want to do some
distributed computation tasks like
distributed matrix multiplication or
descriptive gradient descent or
something like that and the idea is that
you can um
uh
uh add redundancy to your data so
basically encode it with error
correcting code before sending it off to
the compute nodes in order to speed up
your computation in some way so for
example maybe you want to
deal with stragglers that is compute
nodes that might be slow or
non-responsive
or maybe you just want to reduce the
communication complexity as we've
already seen so again this sort of has a
similar flavor
um and yeah and again our work does have
some implications in code of computation
um you know for computation of linear
functions but again it's a very big area
uh and there's a lot of really exciting
work going on um which also sort of has
this pleasure
okay so i'm running out of time so i'll
just say there are a bunch of other uh
questions that have this flavor some of
them even classical like once you start
thinking about this like a lot of
different questions in coding theory can
be shoehorned into this general
framework at least for very specific
classes of functions
um
and sort of getting to the visions of
the future uh you know i think that this
is a really natural notion um
and uh
it's especially the low bandwidth part
i've been seeing a lot recently and i
think that sort of this notion of
efficient computation on top of error
correction it's showing up on a lot of
places and it seems like it might be
important going forward i really think
it deserves being studied in kind of a
unified way as opposed to an ad hoc way
for lots of different families of
functions and lots of slightly different
settings from lots of
many different communities
um i think there's probably a lot to be
gained by putting it together
okay um so i should wrap up so i just
want to have just one more vision of the
future uh if i may um this is a much
more concrete vision i'm looking into my
um my my coding theory crystal ball here
and i'm seeing
i'm seeing a workshop right here yeah um
so
at uh stock uh
slash theory fest 2022 in less than a
month um i'm going to be co-organizing a
workshop on recent advances in coding
theory with noga ron zui um so it's
three days during stock we have a
fantastic lineup of speakers if you'll
be at stock uh please stop by it's gonna
be fabulous
and um one other thing that i just now
recently started seeing in the future of
um
coding theory is a whole simon's program
on coding theory which was just approved
um so uh co-organized with sibicon
scopey uh vancock or swami henry fischer
and jealous and more um we'll be
organizing a simus institute program on
coding theory in spring 2024 so mark
your calendars okay so i'll stop now
once again happy birthday to the simons
institute
thank you mary any questions for mary
so uh like your last slide with this
idea of um
you know the whole computation
on uh coding
the homomorphic secretary so it comes to
mind you know danielis talk when he was
talking about this definition of
amorphism this alternate definition i
don't know if you were here yesterday
morning when daniela spoke about this
composed
composing functions rather than the
traditional homomorphic and i was
wondering suppose you have two uh
you know two
pieces of information
it's stored in an error correcting code
version and now you want to do a
computation on both of them
uh in that form
you know it might be an interesting
place to look at yeah that's a really
great suggestion yeah and actually one
of the things that i was intending to
say on this slide but i guess i went
through it a little quickly is that i
think it would be a great idea to sort
of take as a model for how to approach
this question like what happens when you
replace error correction with crypto or
like with with cryptographic uh
encoding because that's that's a
question that's been extremely well
studied and very very fruitfully so um
yeah and yeah i think that's a fantastic
suggestion for taking some of those
ideas you know about composability and
stuff and applying it here i haven't
thought about it myself but yeah thank
you very much that's really good
any any other questions
so
is it correct that they often when you
use this distributed storage you are
actually
storing many many code words in parallel
and is there like a chance of
amortization or some kind of saving uh
using that yeah that's a great question
yeah so the question is like um you know
typically uh in actual distributed
storage systems the data is kind of like
striped right so you're storing lots of
different code words um in parallel
actually a picture on a hidden slide
somewhere
um
good maybe not oh yeah there it is
so yeah so the picture actually looks
looks more like this um yeah and the
question is is there a chance for
amortization so actually i'm implicitly
already using that um you notice that i
was always talking about download
bandwidth and never about upload
bandwidth um and the reason that that's
okay kind of is it's because of this you
can sort of amortize the upload
bandwidth away um yeah to get
more things yeah so uh
one one another option for amortization
which applies to our work is um
you might have uh right so i was only
working over extension fields but
in a lot of cases it's much nicer to
work over prime fields you can embed
that integers there or for other reasons
you might want to work over prime fields
and if you want to work over a prime
field
you can actually use our scheme for that
by kind of packing things into an
extension field and advertising and
doing a bunch at once um so maybe that's
another opportunity for memorization but
um yeah it's a good question there must
be other opportunities that take
advantage of that striping that's a
really good question
all right let's think mary again